يعني التقدم الروسي في الشرق وتحديدا في
منطقه دونيسك هو واقع الان يعني اقر به
الرئيسكي وكبار القاده في الجيش الاوكراني
كذلك يعني تاتينا المعلومات طباعا من
جبهات القتال من مصادرنا في جبهات القتال
التي تتحدث عن يعني هجمات واسعه وعمليات
اقتحام كبيره يقوم بها جيش الاتحاد الروسي
تحديدا في منطقه دونسك هذه الهجمات وهذا
هذه الاقتحامات التي تقوم بها القوات
الروسيه هي في بعض المناطق يعني يعني تؤدي
الى السيطره على مراكز قليله حول مدينه
باق والتحديدا ولكن الهدف الرئيسي هو
الضغط على القوات داخل مدينه باكموت
لاجبارها على الانسحاب ما يتناوله داخل
الاوكراني ما يتناوله الخبراء العسكريين
وكذلك المحللين حول هذا الامر طبعا ان
الرو يركزون لي قبل نهايه او قبل الذكرى
او حتى في هذه الفتره القريبه ان يسيطروا
على منطقه
بالكامل للفراغ لمناطق اخرى كالجنوب ثم
بعد ذلك تحقيق تقدم في منطقه خرسون وغير
ذلك طبعا الان التركيز الاساسي على دونسك
وعلى اذا تحدثنا عن لوغانسك فالقوات
الروسيه الان تقوم بحجز كبير جدا للقوه
للمعدات في منطقه لوكاس هي لا تحقق تقدما
على الارض ولكنها تحسد الموارد القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول التقدم ولكن تقدمها الذي
اعلنت عنه بطيء جدا بسبب عمليات الزرع
الالغام الواسعه في تلك المنطقه والتي
يعني تحول دون التقدم بسرعه اكبر في منطقه
لوكاس اما في كما افادت القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وكذلك انا استمعت الى شهادات
من عدد من الجنود في الجبهه الذين يقولون
ان الاعداد كبيره المشكله الاساسيه
والرئيسيه الان هو باعداد كبيره جدا من
قبل القوات الروسيه يقولون
على تقدم يعني
ولكن اسمح لي ان اسالك عن
المعارك التي يعملها يعملها الحكومه
الداخليه في اوكرانيا هل من اسباب ذكرت
حول هذا
التصفيه التي يقوم بها ربما
نعم في الحقيقه هنالك اسباب واسباب
موضوعيه جدا اولا قضايا الفساد التي ظهرت
في الداخل الاوكراني زيلينسكي يحاول ان
يعني ان يجعل الجبهه الداخليه متماسكه
وهنا العنصر الاساسي في ذلك الشعب اذا غضب
الشعب على الحكومه والشعر بفساد الحكومه
هذا الامر سوف يزعزع الجبهه الداخليه
للدوله الاوكرانيه وفي الحقيقه هذا هو
الركيز الاساسيه التي تعتمد عليها السلطات
الاوكرانيه
لمجابهه هذه الحرب فهو يحاول اولا ان يرضي
الداخل يحاول ان يقضي على الفساد داخل
الحكومه ولكن هنالك هدف استراتيجي اخر
طبعا الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
تعلمين ان غدا سوف تكون القمه الاوروبيه
مع رئيس المجلس الاوروبي والرئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه